Halt! Da kommt etwas angeritten!
Das sind bestimmt die fünf Fruchtigen, wir hätten den Süsswarenladen nicht ausrauben sollen.
Sind das einfach Waffeln, die auf Fernrein...
Ruhe!
Gleich sind sie da. Au, mein Rücken tut weh. Ah, ist bloss der T-Rex. Ja, danke, ist abgenommen, der kann so raus. Vielen Dank an Manuel für dieses Intro. der passt so, da haben wir keine Anmerkungen mehr. Wir haben keine Anmerkungen mehr, ganz einfach. Das kann so gesagt. Schick's einfach so an die Andrea schon mal. Ja, und dann soll auch mal der Thorsten nochmal drüber gucken, einfach weil der meinte, er hat Erfahrung mit. Ja genau, der Thorsten, der meinte, der kennt sich aus mit Humor, dann soll der da nochmal drüber gucken. Den haben wir doch mal in dieses Seminar geschickt, Weiterentwicklung, das Wochenendseminar Humor in Reda-Wiedenbrück. Genau, rotenase.de, da kam noch dieser Clown und hat da so ein Seminar gehalten über Unterhaltung, der kennt sich da aus, der war mal auf so einem Unterhaltungszimmer. Der war mal da und deswegen soll er noch mal drüber gucken und dann Andrea schicken, aber dann ungeblinkt uns beiden in CC setzen. Ja, bitte in CC. Dann können wir noch was dazu schreiben, dann können wir uns ein bisschen moderierter hinschicken. Alles klar. Danke. Wunderbar, aber kann so raus, wir sind begeistert. Tür. Wir fanden es sehr, sehr lustig. Nein, vielen Dank an Manuel, fantastisch. Vielen, vielen Dank, die fünf Fruchtigen. Ja genau, verstehe jetzt niemand, der uns erst seit dieser Folge hört. Überhaupt versteht niemand, was hier gerade passiert ist. Aber verstehe, wer du bist. Ich bin Stefan Tietze, der, der fragt, ist Florentin Will. Immer der, der fragt, ist Florentin Will. Der, wo der Daumen links ist.
Genau, ich bin der Frager. Genau.
Du hast die Antworten heute im Gepäck.
So, und du hast dich auch gefragt, der Fragende, nämlich, ja, irgendwas zu den Fünffruchtigen. Das sind diese Waffeln. Ich will da jetzt auch nicht ins Detail gehen. Aber ich esse zu viel davon. Ich habe wirklich gemerkt, ich habe einen Geschmack wie ein Kleinkind, weil wenn ich würde ich sagen,, meine Lieblingssüßigkeiten sind die fünf fruchtigen, das sind diese grellen, wirklich fast schon blendend hellen Waffeln. Gleisenden. Also da kann es nicht mit rechten Dingen zugehen, die haben noch nie irgendwas Natürliches in ihrem Leben berührt, sondern direkt irgendwie aus der Chemiefabrik. Und was ich auch noch mag, ist dieser bunte Puffreis. Diese Knall, also wirklich reiner Zucker, Knall, Zucker plus Farbstoff ist, glaube ich, die Kombination, die mich einfach kitzelt. Spannend, was sagt das über dich aus, so rein humanistisch, dass du genau das willst im Supermarkt, was maximal unbiologisch, unecht aussieht. Ich will das Künstlichste, das Klebrigste, das Kleinkindhafteste, wo wirklich selbst, ich glaube, ein Achtjähriger schon sagt, ich nehme eine dunkle Schokolade. Dieses süße Zeug, das mundet mir gar nicht mehr so. Ich mag das Süße gar nicht mehr so. Ich mag die Herrenschokolade. Ich mag die Spargel und Blumenkohl. Genau wie diese, die Osterhasen mit dunkler Schokolade. Ja, wir denken, Zielgruppe, Fragezeichen, als ob irgend so ein Kind dann irgendwie sucht und dann irgendwie im Komposthaufen dann diesen dunklen Schokoladen Osterhasen findet und dann sagt, oh, die mit Kakao, die mit 70 Prozent Kakao-Mutter. Danke dir, die Mutter an mir. Ja, weil das Jahr davor so ein Desaster war, wo er den Normalen gefunden hat und dann gesagt hat, Muttern, ich habe das Ziel gesagt. Ich habe Alpenmilch, das soll man ja auch gar nicht machen. Zum einen aus ökologischen Gründen, zum anderen aus ökonomischen Gründen. Und ich mag das auch einfach nicht. Also ich bitte eher ein bisschen dunklen Schokolade. Nee, bitte nicht das süße Zeug. Ich bin auch ein bisschen, ich bin auch Laktoseintoleranz, ich kriege ein bisschen Probleme mit den Lanzen. Und könnt ihr mir vielleicht eine Cola-Schorle machen, mir ist das sonst zu süss, also ich würde das gern ein bisschen weniger. Oder gleich direkt einen Kaffee, danke, schwarz, danke, danke, nerviges Kind. Ich bin das genaue Gegenteil, ich bin welches jüngste purer Zucker, ich schreie nach Zucker. Ja, nach unechtem bisschen, kann man mal untersuchen, weil ich erinnere mich noch genau, wie wir in New York waren. Und du bist an dem Whole Foods, an dem ganzen organischen Kram. Und ehrlich gesagt, Whole Foods ist vor allem voll keine Gentechnik, einfach organischer, biologischer, echter Kram. Hast du einen Gutscheincode? Daran, ich liebe, mit dem Code UFO könnt ihr da bestimmt nichts bekommen, sondern wahrscheinlich werdet ihr gesperrt. Amerikanischen Bioladen, ja. Mit dem Gutein von UFO müsst ihr 20 Prozent mehr zahlen. Gebt mal überall, wo so ein Gutscheinfenster ist, mal den Code UFO ein und mal gucken, erst mal gibt es noch andere Podcasts, fragwürdig andere Podcasts mit dem Namen UFO. Ja, das stimmt. Und dann kann es ja sein, dass wir in Zukunft mal Werbung für die machen und das noch nicht gesagt haben. haben. Aber können wir irgendeine Kooperation mit irgendeiner Firma machen, wo man mehr zahlen muss mit unserem Code? Einfach so eine Firma, die wir gar nicht mögen. Einfach irgendwie wirklich so eine Firma, wo wir sagen, nein, die lehnen wir ab. Da sollen unsere Leute bestraft werden, wenn sie da einkaufen mit unserem Gutscheincode. Ja, Reinmetall oder sowas vielleicht. Ja, sowas. Falls ihr euch schön so eine Panzerhaubitze besorgen wollt übers Wochenende, müsst ihr ordentlich draufzahlen. Ordentlich draufzahlen. Und da bist du halt immer an diesen ganzen Regalen vorbeigegangen, zu den Regalen, wo es bunt wurde, wo die Foodloops, wo für die Kinder dann auch so die Foodloops, ja, diese ganzen Maskottchen auf diesen Verpackungen waren, dann plötzlich weg und dann hin zu den zu den krass gefärbten Farben. Ja. Diese krassen gleißenden Farben, die ihm das Auge wegfräsen. Da bist du hin.
Ich kann auch immer dieses Argument nicht verstehen, so ja, das schmeckt ja gar nicht nach echter Erdbeere. Das ist ja nur Erdbeergeschmackstoff. Nicht so, ja, ich mag aber den Geschmack von dem Geschmacksverstärker, den mag ich. Die Erdbeere selber interessiert mich überhaupt nicht. Es schmeckt ja nicht besser, nur weil es natürlich ist. Ich will ehrlich gesagt lieber, dass echte Erdbeeren so schmecken wie der Erdbeergeschmack von Fritt, als ob die Gentechnik das nicht. Es schmeckt ja nicht besser, nur weil es natürlich ist. Ich will ehrlich gesagt lieber, dass echte Erdbeeren so schmecken wie der Erdbeergeschmack von Fritt, als ob die Gentechnik das nicht könnte, zu sagen, lass uns mal die echten Erdbeeren nach Fritt schmecken lassen, nach Erdbeerfritt. Warum geht das denn nicht? Ja, das finde ich eine gute Idee. Er sagt, dass die Natur es immer besser kann. Ganz im Gegenteil, die Natur baut nur Nonsens die ganze Zeit.
Krankheiten, Tiere, die ekelhaft sind, die stinken.
So, der Mensch kann das besser, der soll sagen, nein, Zitrone schmeckt jetzt so wie dieser Klostein, so schmeckt jetzt eine echte Zitrone. Aber das stimmt, die Natur baut wirklich nur Nonsens. Und alles, was funktioniert, ist reiner Zufall. Warum haben wir keine Schuhe, warum haben wir keine Hufe, müssen wir extra selber bauen. Hufe wäre auch geil, Menschen mit Hufen. Aber kannst halt schlecht gleichen, ne? Dann machst du so Filzgleiter drunter. Also du meinst, du müsstest dir dann zum Schleichen extra Schuhe anziehen, wo man wir uns zum Schleichen extra die Schuhe ausziehen. Das heißt, du brauchst dann eigentlich diese Filzdinger, damit du nicht kloppe die klopst. Da gehst du einen Schuster kannst du dir einen Filzgleiter kaufen und dann kannst du nicht, du kannst so gleiten. Ja. Du kannst es langsam, ohne das Parkett zu zerkratzen. Ja. Das ist der Unterschied zwischen Katzen und Hunden. Hunde haben ja immer ihre Krallen ausgefahren, Katzen fahren die ein. Und allein als Kind fand ich das schon faszinierend, weil ich dachte, Katzen und Hunde sind quasi dasselbe. Ja. So, halt das eine ist männlich, das andere ist weiblich, klar. Das eine ist rechts vom Fuchs, das andere ist links vom Fuchs. Im Grunde ist das gleiche,we so, wegen des Löwen. Das ist jetzt völlig aus dem Kontext gegriffen, weil es ja viel Quatsch ist, als ob wir Zebras töten. Lass uns das mal machen. Mit so ausgestopften, gruseligen Tieren. Und dann Stimmen drüber. Ja. Und dann die lustigsten deutschen Stimmen drüber. Ja, und die wackeln dann auch nur so. Das so ausgestopften Tiere, das ist ja auch ein Markt, der, glaube ich, einknickt. Die wenigsten Leute wollen noch ausgestopften Tieren, ich glaube, früher war das völlig selbstverständlich, dass du einfach einen ausgestopften Biber in das Wohnzimmer stellst, heute eher wenig. Also da ist ja ein gewisser Bestand von ausgestopften Tieren, der jetzt irgendwo hin muss. Ja, ich verstehe auch nicht genau, also die sind ja schon tot. Gut, aber dann, wo fängt man da jetzt an? Ich will auch dieses Das ist die alte Pelzfrage. Jetzt bin ich wieder in so einem Standpunkt, naja gut, wenn man halt anderthalb Stunden pro Woche redet, landet man irgendwann an Standpunkten, die man selber nicht hat, weil ich sage, ich spreche das trotzdem mal aus. Ich hab das. Man könnte ja, was spricht denn dagegen? Die sind ja schon tot, diese ausgeschopften Dinge, die können wir uns doch jetzt einfach mal hier an die Wand hängen, warum denn nicht? Das Studio ist noch kahl hier, in dem wir jetzt gerade sitzen. Wir können da so einen grossen Hirsch hinstellen. Ja, das ist dieses alte gebrauchter Pelz-Problem. Wenn du den gebrauchten Pelz kaufst, natürlich willst du keine Pelze kaufen, dann musst du mir jemanden sterben. Aber der ist ja schon tot. So, und dann ist die Frage, soll man es dann noch wegschmeißen oder nicht? Und deswegen, falls ihr was zu Hause habt und es wird unangenehm, schickt es gerne an uns. Wir wollen so einen schönen Biber hier. Und wenn ihr gute Gegenargumente habt, warum das nicht stimmt, diese, wenn die sind ja schon tot, Argumentation, dann schickt sie uns gerne auch. Mal ein Bild, wo ihr mit schöner Font so, also wirklich so mit so Zapfino oder wirklich so schöner Kalligrafieschrift uns wirklich ein gutes, saftiges Gegenargument um die Ohren scheppert. Ja. Und das schön in Bildform hängen wir uns gerne an die Wand, damit wir auch erinnert werden, dass wir nicht immer recht haben. Ich habe zu wenig Meinung für das Internet, glaube ich. Ja? Ja. Sie brauchen so viel Meinung, um mitmachen zu dürfen? Ja, und so ist es ein bisschen das Internet auch. Also gerade besteht das auch noch, also Twitter und Instagram, die beiden Medien, wo ich bin, funktionieren nur noch über Meinung. Alle hauen immer eine Meinung raus, alle haben immer eine Meinung. Und ich bin immer, egal in welche Richtung, erst mal neidisch auf diese Meinung, weil da so viel Meinung hintersteht. Ich habe das Problem, ich habe oft eine Meinung zu spät. Ich merke so, oh, jetzt langsam komme ich an den Punkt, wo ich eine Meinung habe zu dem Thema von vor einem halben Jahr und dann will ich aber jetzt nicht einen provokanten Tweet raushauen. Ich habe jetzt eine Meinung zur Wirecard. Also so in der letzten Woche ist das so entstanden. Jetzt habe ich ja ein Masterleck, ich habe beide Seiten gehört, ich habe das abgeglichen, ich habe die Akteneinsicht bekommen, jetzt habe ich mir das angeschaut und jetzt habe ich eine Meinung, jetzt interessiert sich niemand mehr dafür. Deswegen habe ich mir überlegt, ob das nicht echt eine geile, aber wahrscheinlich beurteilst du, du bist jetzt Mathilde 5. Oh Gott, also muss ich eine Meinung haben. Aber nicht jetzt, nicht jetzt. Wie wäre die Show die Too Late Show? Das ist meine Idee, Too Late Show. Und zwar behandelt die immer die Themen vom letzten Monat. So, immer was war vor einem Monat oder ungefähr einem Monat, wo man einfach sagt, so jetzt wissen wir, was los ist, jetzt haben wir beide Seiten gehört. Ist ja oft so, dass irgendwie Enthüllung, der hat was falsch gemacht und jeder hat eine Meinung, bevor der andere überhaupt gesagt hat, sorry, das habt ihr völlig, mich schreibt man mit Y, nicht mit I, mich schreibt man ganz anders, ich bin ein ganz anderer. Und bevor die Person das überhaupt sagen konnte, hat jeder die Meinung, sondern dass man nach einem Monat nochmal zurückkommt. Sehr gut. Aber was sagst du dann jetzt als, erstmal würde ich gerne vorschlagen, als Intro-Song den Harlem Shake oder Gangnam Style oder Crazy Frog oder sowas, irgendwas Too Late-artiges, Dann macht man Witze, die mal früher Too Soon waren. Oder, ja, Not Soon Enough könnt ihr die Serie auch haben. Ich finde Too Late Show eigentlich so gut. Ich erinnere mich aber auch an den Namen. Ich meine, ich habe mal eine Rubrik gegrübelt. Nee, nee, nee, wir wollten bei Gute Arbeit und Regen jetzt die Too Soon Show machen, wo wir immer, unsere Idee war folgende, sobald irgendwas Schlimmes in der Welt passiert, irgendjemand stirbt, Bombe, was auch immer, wir setzen uns am selben Abend noch hin, schreiben Gags zu diesem Thema, am nächsten Tag zeichnen wir auf und hauen die Too-Soon-Show raus aus diesem, man darf kurz nach einem schlimmen Ereignis keine Gags machen, wir wollten exakt das machen, nennen es aber auch die Too-Soon-Show, um allen zu sagen, Leute, wer da keinen Bock drauf hat, schaut es sich nicht an, aber wer einfach jetzt Bock auf die schnellen Gags hat, schaut es euch an, aber überraschenderweise haben wir das dann doch nicht gemacht. Oder wir haben es gemacht, aber dann halt durch unseren auffälligen Postprozess haben wir es dann erst drei Wochen später veröffentlicht und dann war es völlig okay. Die Grafiken und all das. Wir mussten es einfach gute Arbeit Originals nennen, anstatt too soon show.
Das war dann... Und ich glaube, wir waren zu faul, dass wenn wir dann irgendwie
am Samstagnachmittag hören, oh, jetzt ist eine Rakete explodiert,
und wir so jetzt schnell ins Büro jetzt schreiben,
Writers Room und dann durchballern.
Aber ich finde die Idee immer noch nicht schlecht,
aber too late show ist, glaube ich,
es ist angenehmer, weil du ja gerade keine Arbeit machen musst.
Ich soll eine Meinung haben.
Ja, also wie finden Sie die Idee? Ach so, wie finden Sie die Idee? Muss ich mich da jetzt schon... Sie haben oft getrunken, während wir geredet haben. Haben Sie überhaupt gehört, was wir gesagt haben? Sie hatten fast die Hälfte des Gesprächs, hatten Sie die Flasche am Mund. Was ist denn los? Warum trinken Sie so viel? So warm in diesem Raum. Aber können, sollen wir noch mal anfangen, haben Sie jetzt genug getrunken? Nee, ich will mich nicht noch nicht festnageln lassen, kann ich Ihnen meine Meinung innerhalb der nächsten zwei Monate mitteilen. Okay, dann habe ich vielleicht eine Meinung, ist vielleicht zu late. Aber weil ich und entweder ist es keine Meinung haben oder zu wenig Meinung haben oder es ist das Bewusstsein, dass ich eh zu wenig darüber weiß. Vielleicht ist es das bei mir, dass ich keine Meinung habe, weil ich immer das Gefühl habe, ich weiß da jetzt eh gerade zu wenig darüber. Das finde ich wiederum eine schöne Eigenschaft. Und was ich aber auch an mir beobachte, ist, dass ich immer die Meinung habe von dem oder derjenigen, die zuletzt auf mich eingewirkt hat mit der Meinung. Weil wenn ich auch so True Crime Shows gucke, also man könnte mir immer vorher zwei Shirts drucken von dem oder der Angeklagten und dem oder dem Opfer. Und dann, also keine Ahnung, da gibt es ja dann immer nach jeder, meistens nach jedem Cliffhanger ist man dann, bin ich komplett auf der einen Seite, komplett auf der anderen Seite. Es gibt dieses Zwischending nicht. Man kann sich mit so einer Fahne und so einem Shirt da hinsetzen. Ich weiß noch, bei damals The Staircase, wo es darum ging, ob so ein Mann von so einer Eule getötet wurde. Ich hab das nur am Rande mit Rückblick. Rückblickend ging das noch. Komische Runden. Ja, aber das war die letzte Meinung, die ich gehört habe, deswegen glaub ich auch immer noch, dass eine Eule diese Frau getürzt hat und nicht der Mann, der schon zweimal davor im Klasse war. Welche Eule ist die Frage? Ja, das ... uh. Aber bei welchem Thema kennst du dich gut genug aus, dass du am selben Tag noch eine Meinung hast? Also, wo du sagst so, ich bin einfach richtig Thema Torf, bin ich drin, und wenn jetzt der Landwirtschaftsminister sagt, Freunde, wir müssen weniger Torf verbrennen, sagst du instant, da weiß ich genug, um jetzt sofort in die Tasten zu hauen. Aber jetzt geht es auch darum, europäischer Torf, gemeiner, und da würde ich mich dann auch schon vom asiatischen Torf würde ich mich schon distanzieren, weil da weiß ich nicht mehr so viel. Ich bin da, ich weiß sehr wenig. Es ist schwierig. Das ist schwierig, aber du hast eine Meinung zur Hitze, du bist ... Ja, eine Meinung zur Hitze und ich habe eine Meinung zu Dinosauriern. Dinosaurier, Dinosaurier, du musst aufpassen, dass du nicht aufgegessen wirst. Jeder kennt das berühmte Lied. Aber du kannst doch erst mal generell aufpassen. Passt mal schön auf. Ja, aufgepasst. Wir haben unsere bliebte Rubrik lange nicht mehr gemacht. Es geht um die Rubrik Dino News. Wir spielen den Jingle an dieser Stelle nicht mehr ab, weil Too Late Show. Also, Dinos machen gerade sehr viele Dinge durch. Wir leben in einer heißen Phase, habe ich das Gefühl. Seit ein paar Monaten, ja, beziehungsweise das letzte Jahr, müssen wir eigentlich ein sehr zeitaktuelles Phänomen, müssen wir beobachten, wie der Dino an Coolness verliert. Ja, und man muss ja auch sagen, viele Dino-Filme sind aktuell in Produktion und pausiert, weil die gerade da sitzen, die eine Maskenbildnerin hat einen Haufen Federn in der Hand, die andere Maskenbildnerin hat einen Haufen Schuppen, dann hat einer noch irgendwie so gelbe Farbe, grüne Farbe und alle sagen, was denn jetzt? Genau. Und der Regisseur packt das ein ins Lager, lasst uns noch ein Jahr warten und dann klebt irgendwas. Pack die Federn in ganz grosse Kisten ins Lager. Pack die Federn ins Lager, die schuppen gleich dazu und die gelbe Farbe, pack sie weg, wir brauchen sie nur nicht. Und dann packt er das alles weg und dann erst in einem Jahr gibt es paläontologische Gutachten, wo man sagt, jetzt sind sie gelb oder nicht. Ich glaube, Schlager fände ich dann cool, wenn es um sehr spezifische Themen geht. Pack die Farbe wieder ein. Pack die Federn wieder ein. Es geht als Schlager aus der Sicht eines Regisseurs, der einen Dino-Film macht für Apple Plus. Das ist die grobe Lockline. Weil das ist spannend, weil Schlager ist ja immer sehr relatable. Es geht immer darum ... Die Berge erstrahlen. Griechischer Wein. Ja. Wobei das auch schon sehr speziell ist, das muss man auch später als verstanden. Ja, türkischer Honig. Türkischer Honig, asiatischer Flieder. Ja. So, aber auch dieses, ne, die Berge-Naturkram und dann aber auch so, ich finde sie schön, ich habe mich verliebt und so weiter. Also dieser typischen Relatable Freundinnen-Freund-Kram. Und stattdessen konkret? Stattdessen konkret packt die Federn wieder ein. Aber kurze Frage, gibt es eigentlich ein Schlager-Musical? Ja. Ja? Ja. Erstmal, gut, jetzt Hot Take, Mamma Mia. Okay. Okay. Weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß es auch nicht. Und dann war doch neulich so ein weirder Film im Kino, weil Kreuzfahrtschiff und so alle haben gesungen. Ach so. Ja, aber es gibt schon Schlager-Musicals. Willst du Schlager-Musicals machen? Ich dachte gerade, vielleicht ist das was, oder ich habe mir nachgedacht, welche Musicals es noch nicht gibt, vielleicht Elektro, Elektro-Musical, so ein Daft-Punk-Musical. Gibt's auch schon. Ja, bestimmt. Aber jetzt ist noch nicht in Deutschland geschwappt. Ja. So, aber wir haben neue News. Ich will nicht die Dino-News hören! Pass auf, ich habe eine sehr gute Nachricht für dich. Ich hab eine sehr schlechte Nachricht für dich. Was willst du zuerst hören?
Ich hab auch eine sehr, sehr gute Nachricht.
Ich will erst die sehr, sehr gute hören.
Also die sehr, sehr gute Nachricht.
Der Tyrannosaurus Rex.
Ich selbst war in der Ausstellung damals in New York, hab mir angeguckt, was der neueste Stand ist.
Der war sehr ernüchternd.
Daher kommt das Bild mit den grauen Härchen und den Federn und dem kleinen Küken, altigen kleinen. Und du ganz enttäuscht daneben. Ja. Die haben gemerkt, ich bin Tourist, wollen ein Foto von mir machen und ich dann sehr traurig vor diesem nicht so grossen Tier ist. Und er sah auch traurig aus. Tier ist ein bisschen glücklicher aus als ich mit seinen kleinen, netten, freundlichen Äuglein. Und seiner Brille. Und der Brille. Und zwar, und da hieß es noch, der konnte gar nicht so schnell rennen, weil... Wegen der Rollschuhe. Wegen der Rollschuhe. Ja. Nee, weil er immer einen Fuß auf dem Boden haben musste, weil sonst bricht ihm alles weg, weil er so schwer ist. Stell sich aus, nein, er konnte sehr, sehr schnell rennen. Ah, okay. Es gibt nämlich neue Untersuchungen seines Beins, also des Knochens, der Fußbeschaffenheit. Da wurde jetzt irgendwie ein Knochen untersucht oder irgendwie neuer gefunden oder so, ein sehr gut erhaltener Fußgelenk-Knochen, Sprunggelenk. Und der konnte wohl wirklich sehr, sehr gut, also er konnte wirklich immer nur so laufen, dass ein Fuß auf dem Boden sein musste, aber das ist in etwa so schnell. Also Walken. Genau, man kann sagen, also wie man es kennt von Olympia, die Disziplin Walken. Ja, Gehen. Ja, also ja, jetzt mal wegdenken von der Optik kurz, mal nur faktische Zahlen. Also sehr hüftlastig. Hüftlastig viel, ne, Po. Und er konnte in etwa so schnell wie ein olympischer Sprinter die Höchstgeschwindigkeit eines olympischen Sprinters. Das kann man sich jetzt gut vorstellen. Stellt euch Usain Bolt vor, der gibt richtig Gas. Der ist ja zehnmal so gross. Hundert Meter. Der kann auch so schnell laufen wie eine Katze, das ist ja keine Kunst. Wie so ein schnell rennender Käfer. Ja eben, wie so eine schnelle Ente. Fliegen oder geht's? Oder ist Ente Mensch ungefähr, Mensch der T-Rex? Oder welches Tier ist im Verhältnis zu uns so klein, wie der Mensch zum T-Rex ist? Ja, das ist der langweiligste Google-Aufruf der Welt. Ein Hund, ein Schaf oder eine Ziege oder so? Das kriegen wir mal raus. Das finde ich auch lustig. Verhältnis Mensch T-Rex. Also der geht denen doch bis zur Hüfte oder was heißt Hüfte, wenn der so nach vorne gebeugt hat. Die gehen ja immer so gekrümmt, die T-Rex-Leute. Der T-Rex war so gross, so gross ungefähr, ähm, sechs Komma eins Tonnen. Neun Komma fünf, sechs Komma eins Tonnen. Ja, Tonnen. Jetzt rechnen wir das um auf. Sechs Komma eins Tonnen, also sechstausend Kilo. Ein Mensch wiegt hundert Kilo, also sechzig Mal. Sechzig Mal. Also von uns runtergerechnet, ein Sechzigstel von hundert ist dann ungefähr zwei Kilo. Zwei Kilo. Ein Huhn. Ein Huhn. Ein Tier, ein Komm,6 Kilogramm, also in etwa ... Was wiegt es für ein Huhn? Oder so ein Salamander? Ja, Huhengewicht ist, glaube ich, das wäre auch jetzt gut eigentlich. Ja, 1,5 Kilo, also ein Huhn. Okay, ein Huhn, okay, das heißt, der Mensch kann schneller oder langsamer laufen als ein sprintendes Huhn. So, angenommen, nee, ein olympisches, nee, wir reden jetzt von den besten Hühnern. Da muss man aufpassen. Die Olympiade der Tiere. Der Übertrag. Also, wir reden von Hühner sind eine, und jetzt geht es auch darum, Hühner sind eine technisch hoch versierte Spezies. Stimmt, Hühner sind ja wie T-Rex eigentlich. Das passt ja eigentlich ganz gut. Aber stell dich mal vor, Hühner, wenn wir das genau übertragen wollen, weil ich meine, wir Menschen sind ja auch clever und haben deswegen krasse Trainingsmethoden, und Nussan Bolt wurde crazy gut trainiert und ist deswegen nur so schnell. Stell dich jetzt eine Huhn-Zivilisation vor, die das auch alles hingekriegt hat, haben Banken, die haben eine tolle, tolle funktionierte Wirtschaft, so, und jetzt haben die auch krasse Trainingsmethoden. Und aus dem hervorgehend, das beste Huhn ist, das ist so schnell wie wir.
Du meinst, das beste Huhn der Welt kann schneller laufen als wir.
So, stell dir mal vor, wie schnell wir laufen müssten, um dieses Huhn zu erreichen.
Und zwar als Walking, als Olympische Walking-Disziplin, wo wir nicht die Bodenhaftung verlieren dürfen.
Soweit ich weiss, ist die Schwierigkeit dabei, einen Huhn zu fangen, nicht die, dass Hühner schnell sind, sondern dass sie wendiger sind.
Ich glaube, ein Mensch ist schneller. Sonst hätte er ja nie einen Menschen Huhn fangen können. Sonst hätten wir ja gar keine Hühner.
Oder? Also wären Hühner schneller als Menschen, erklären wir den KFC am Hauptbahnhof. Wie klappt das? Wie haben wir, ich habe mir das gefragt, als ich im Kölner Zoo war und dann waren die Geparden und es stand das schnellste Tier der Welt. Ich dachte mir, es ist hier, also irgendjemand muss uns fangen können. Ja, aber ich war es nicht. Fahrrad oder Motorrad oder so.
Ja, aber es ist schwierig.
I don't bite.
Also, ihr stellt euch vor, schnellste Huhn der Welt und wir laufen genauso schnell daneben.
Ich finde, dann laufen wir schon ziemlich schnell.
Und wenn man jetzt noch das imposante Tier Tyrannosaurus Rex sich anguckt. Hühner flitzen! Ja. Scheiße. Das kann man auch nicht so gut vergleichen. Also Huhn und T-Rex wiederum sehr, aber ich glaube, ich helfe unseren Punkt jetzt nicht genau. Jedenfalls, der läuft wie schnell wie der krasseste Sprinter und das über mehrere Stunden kann der so schnell laufen. Und das ist schon ziemlich beeindruckend. Ich fand das ziemlich beeindruckend. Wo will der hin? Ja, wovor laufst du davon? Das kann man auch fragen. Also, ein Huhn, die Höchstgeschwindigkeit eines Huhn sind 14 kmh. Ja, aber das kann man jetzt nicht umrechnen. Das ist jetzt fast vergleichen. Naja, aber ein Mensch. Aber das ist jetzt Unsinn. Wie schnell ist denn ein olympischer Sprinter? Naja, oh, ein rennender männlicher Mensch ist bei 13 kmh. Und ein Huhn auf 14 kmh, laut Google. Das Huhn ist schneller als der rennende Mensch. Olympischer Sprintergeschwindigkeit. What? 45 kmh. Ich habe hier 13 kmh. Rennend. Ja, joggend. Google schreibt rennend. Usain Bolt erreichte bei seinem Rekordlauf 9,58 Sekunden, eine Spitzengeschwindigkeit von rund 12,5 m pro Sekunde oder 44,72 km h. Das heißt, 45 km h ist er gelaufen. So. Und so schnell kann ein T-Rex-Konto 45 km h laufen. Okay. Ja, gut, das ist die beste Neuigkeit, die wir haben seit langem. Also er würde in der Ortschaft nicht mal bestraft werden. Also in der 30er-Zolle würde er geblisst. Er würde ordentlich geblisst werden. Aber nicht sein Gesicht. Und seine kleinen Eugleinen würden dann um, um, um, und dann würde er umfallen. Und es wäre ein Riesen, dann würde er so peinlich erst in so einen Wassertrog fallen und dann in so Federn rein. Ach nee, auch schon, leider schon Federn. Darf man so Edamame-Schale aus dem Fenster werfen im Auto? Man darf auch Zigaretten aus dem Fenster werfen im Auto. Nein, aber das soll man nicht machen. Nee, nee, aber man soll auch nicht mit Edamame um sich werfen. Also du kannst ja, wenn du im Wald spazieren gehst und eine Bananenschale weg wirst, ist okay. Du meinst, du hast Angst, die deutsche Biologie auseinanderzubringen, Flora und Fauna verrückt zu machen, wenn du da mit ihrem Arme umherläufst? Ich frage mich, weil Autofahrer werfen manchmal Müll aus dem Fenster, da werde ich Fuchsteufelswild, das macht man nicht. Aber eine leere Bananenschale, darf man die während der Autofahrt, also nicht, dass natürlich, ich denke jetzt an kein Mario-Kart-Szenario, das natürlich auf der Autobahn vorsichtig sein soll. Schildkröten-related. Aber würdest du sagen, ist es okay? Also angenommen, du würdest jetzt, also du hast ein Date, sagen wir mal das zweite Date, sagen wir mal das dritte Date, ihr fahrt irgendwo hin, ihr fahrt zu Ikea, weil irgendwie beim zweiten Date hat sie gesagt, ich habe irgendwie nicht die richtigen Vorhänge bei mir in der Wohnung, die sind lichtdurchlässig und dann ist es morgens immer so hell und dann, weil du bist ein charmant, cooler Typ, schreibst du fürs dritte Date so. Du brauchst auch bald Vorhänge, sowas, so cool? Nee, nee, nee, gar nicht. Du schreibst dann nach dem zweiten Date so, hey, ich hätte ein Auto zur Verfügung, wollen wir nicht jetzt endlich mal für dich die Vorhänge kaufen zu Ikea? Hallo Frau, ich hätte ein Auto zur freien Verfügung. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nicht Frau, das ist das nach dem zweiten Date. Ah ja, okay. Und dann seid ihr auf dem Weg im Auto zu Ikea. Ist jetzt keine grosse Weltreise außenbereich der Stadt. Mein Auto? Dein Auto und jetzt Szenario, sie würde jetzt, sagen wir mal, sie holt sich ein Erfrischungstuch aus ihrer Handtasche, reinigt ihre Hände und wirft es aus dem Fahnenfenster. Ja, Vollbremsung, ich würde Vollbremsung nach, mit quietschenden Reifen, roten Flaggen werden rausgeholt. Ja, quietschenden Reifen, egal ob wir auf einer, we weiß nicht, 70er-Zone, ob wir wissen, mit Kwiezchenreifen halten wir an, Waren blinkt dicht an. Und ich würde sagen, sag mal, geht's noch, würde ich mit Angel Schrie Stefan mit hochrotem Kopf. Also das wäre für dich Red Flag aus. Das war's. Szenario B. Ich würde trotzdem noch Standbauer trotzdem noch mit ihr die Vorhänge kaufen. Weil Entscheidungen wurden getroffen, Geld wurde abgehoben bereits. Sie braucht unbedingt Vorhänge. Sie braucht unbedingt Vorhänge. Und ich würde mich dann aber nicht mehr melden. Ich würde sie dann im Ikea verlieren. Du würdest dich vom Kinderparadies abholen lassen und bist weg.
Und okay, Szenario B. Gleiches Setting, cooler Spruch, hey, die Vorhänge lassen zu Ikea gehen und so.
Ihr sitzt im Auto, sie packt eine Banane aus und isst die Banane auf und wirft die Bananenschale aus dem Auto während der Fahrt. So jetzt. Was ist die Reaktion? Luigi hinter mir tobt. Ja? Ich frage mich gerade, fahren wir durch ein Waldstück? Nö, also stell dir wirklich vor, so aus Köln raus Richtung Industriegebiet, Ikea, sowas. Und dann wirft sie jetzt auf Asphalt. Sie sitzt ja rechts. Wo die Banane dann so comichaft liegen bleibt. Sie sitzt ja rechts, sie sitzt ja auf dem Beifahrer, sitzt ja dein Auto. Du fährst natürlich ganz links auf der Überholspur, klar 160. Sie sitzt rechts, wirft aus ihrem Fenster rechts, damit natürlich auf die Mittelspur oder auf die Strasse direkt. Nee, das geht nicht. Nee, du würdest sagen, geht nicht? Nee. Ähnliche Reaktionen oder wie würdest du dann reagieren? Nee, ich würde dann, glaube ich, ich, weiterfahren und die gelbe Flagge rausholen und sagen, das finde ich schwierig. In Waldwerfen, lustigerweise finde ich irgendwie entspannter. Ganz kurz, ich rede schon davon, dass sie das mit Schwung aus dem Fenster haut. Mit Schmackes. Also nicht so rauslegen oder so neben sich fallen lassen, sondern wirklich mit einem, also sagen wir mal, sie holt ihr rechter Arm jetzt bis zum Schaltknüppel, Höhe Schaltknüppel aus, so richtig mit einem Zack und dann sie öffnet natürlich das Fenster zu drücken. Du meinst gerade, es landet auf der Mittelspur, es landet nicht im angängenden Waldstück. Wo es genau landet, siehst du nicht, du siehst nicht, wo es landet. Du siehst nur, dass sie sich Mühe gibt, es ein Stück zu werfen. Aber du bist natürlich ganz links, zwei Spuren rechts von dir. Wie weit kann sie werfen? Das hattet ihr noch nicht, das Gespräch.
Da unser klares Ziel. So gut kennt ihr euch nicht.
Nee, und deswegen muss ich auch wahrscheinlich das Gespräch vorher führen, demnächst, beim ersten Date bereits.
Aber wir haben ja das klare Ziel formuliert, Ikea gleich.
Ikea-Parkplatz ist ja gespickt von Mülleimern.
Okay.
Ich finde es nicht so schwierig, die war noch ein bisschen länger, aber auch schwierig.
Also ich finde, ich würde ihre ganze... Das Spiel formuliert Ikea gleich. Ikea-Parkplatz ist ja gespickt von Mülleimern. Okay. Ich find's nicht so schwierig, die Banane noch ein bisschen länger. Aber auch schwierig. Ich würde ihr ganzes Leben infrage stellen, warum sie denn zum dritten Date erst mal diese Banane mitbringt. Sie hatte keine Zeit zu frühstücken. Aber warum nicht? Sie hat ja immer diesen Termin abgemacht. Dann soll sie den doch bitte so legen ... Das hab ich doch nicht verstanden, dass sie sich jetzt noch schnell was reinstecken muss. Das brauche ich jetzt nicht unbedingt, also. Aber da würdest du noch drüber wegsehen, aber in Kombination mit dem Rauswerfen ist dann zu viel. Nee, wenn nicht zu viel, aber es würde darüber gesprochen werden. Es wird darüber gesprochen werden. So jetzt Szenario drei, es kommt von von fünfzehn, Edamame. Edamame wäre nicht mal ein Gespräch. Ich würde sie im Podcast erzählen, aber ich würde sie, sie würde davon nicht erfahren. Szenario drei, ihr wart davor noch Brunchen beim Asiaten, schön kleiner Snack. Irgendwie, ich rede jetzt so von so einem Tee mit Edamame, leichten Sachen, sow, weil sie vielleicht, vielleicht hast du so gesagt, ey, wir gehen zu Ikea, schön Köttböller und Hotdog und sie so, ja, ich versuche gerade weniger Fleisch zu essen und so und dann denkst du um, oh, da gibt es wenig Alternativen, vielleicht bei Ikea, also sagst du, hey, dann lass uns doch treffen bei Pau Mau, hierbei bei meinem Lieblingsasiaten und lass uns noch was essen. Und dann
esst sie das und so und dann sagt sie
Edamame, wollen wir die
mitnehmen, so für einen Fahrtsnack oder so?
Ist das für dich okay?
Sie nimmt es mit ins Auto,
sie knabbert so ein bisschen
diese Bohnen raus.
Füttert sie dich so damit? Nee. Nee. Nee. Drittes Date? Nee. Oder? Füttert mich nicht. Okay. Das heißt, du nimmst auch die... Auch weil ich ja fahre. Also ist ja auch nicht so... Okay, also sie auf dem Beifahrersitz knabbert diese Edamame raus, Fenster runter, haut die Edamame-Schale raus. Natürlich, jetzt kommt ein anderer Aspekt des Edamames, ein Edamame kommt selten allein. Korrekt. Das heißt, hier hat sie jetzt vor, also wenn das der erste wäre, würde ich sofort Notbremse ziehen und sagen, okay, einmal ist okay, nein, aber was jetzt folgt, ist ja ein, und das ist ja auch nervig, weil alle da hinter uns fahren, wenn die alle fünf Minuten Scheibenwischer anmachen müssen, weil so fünf Edamard-Dinger auf der Windschutzscheibe gelandet sind. Aber wie gehst du denn mit ... Aber jetzt, ich habe zu wenig Meinung wieder dafür. Ich würde eher behaupten, man kann ja alles wegschmeißen, in den Müll schmeißen, man kann sich auch mal kurz ... Wie lange fährt man denn, dass man dieses zugemüllte Auto so anstrengend findet, dass man mitführungszeichen zu werfen. Sie gibt eine Erklärung ab. Sie sagt, ja, Stefan, ich habe ja hier nur diesen einen Topf und wenn ich jetzt die Hülsen da auch wieder reintue, dann nehme ich ja irgendwann, dann habe ich das Popcornproblem. Wenn du die Popcornkörner in die Popcorn-Tüte tust, steigt die Popcorn-Kerndichte und es wird immer schlimmer, je weiter man geht. Dann sage ich, ja, Linda, wir müssen einfach auch an so einem Zeitmanagement arbeiten, weil... Aber ich fand das doch ganz nett, dass wir was für die Strasse haben, für einen kleinen Roadtrip und was snacken dabei. Ja, aber wenn dann die Konsequenz ist, dass wir in 60-Sekundentakt Edamame aus dem Fenster werfen und es den Ford Focus hinter uns trifft... Dann lass uns doch immer drei Hülsen sammeln und die dann zusammen rauswirken.
Gleichzeitig, das heißt, er muss nur einmal den Scheibenwischer anmachen.
Wir machen beide die Fenster auf bei 160 kmh.
Und dann zähle ich bis drei und jeder wirft drei Hülsen raus.
Okay? Okay.
Das machen wir alle fünf Minuten und das geht dann.
Das finde ich dann okay.
Trotzdem will ich in Zukunft vielleicht darüber nachdenken, ob wir unsere Snacks nicht so einplanen.
Weil gestern das mit der Banane, heute das mit der Edamame und dann hast du deine Erfrischungstücher, übrigens darüber müssen wir auch reden, weil du riechst die ganze Zeit nach Erfrischungstuch. Meine Hände immer voller Edamame-Saft sind, salzig. Dein Edamame-Konsum runterschrauben. Du hast doch das asiatische Restaurant vorgeschlagen. Ja, weil ich das mag und weil du gerne asiatisch isst, aber das, Linda, ich mag es jetzt hier.
Ich glaube, an dieser Stelle, ja, es war schön, aber ... Hä, wie meinst du, wir sind noch nicht mehr bei Ikea? Ja, ne, wir sind dann bei Ikea und danach fahren wir gemeinsam zurück. Oh Gott, ich hasse deine Strategie, Probleme direkt anzusprechen, aber das doch noch durchzuziehen.
Ja, rosa streit und dann wird grummelnd.
Ja, aber die orangen Vorhängen sind ja auch ganz nett, oder?
Und dann sind so stellvertretender Streits.
Also ich habe gesagt, die anderen haben mir besser gefallen.
Die ultramarinen blauen Vorhängen haben mir besser gefallen.
Ja, aber durch blau, da kommt das Licht so gut durch.
Ich will ja eben was haben, was das Licht raus...
Ja, das sind deine Vorhänge, du musst ja kaufen, was du willst. Aber du hast mich ja gerade nach meiner Meinung gefragt. Also du willst mich jetzt überzeugen, weil ich finde die blauen besser. Und jetzt ist es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es ein bisschen, dass es Blau, da kommt das Licht so gut durch. Ich will ja eben was haben, was das Licht raus ... Das sind deine Vorhänge, du musst ja kaufen, was du willst. Du hast mich gerade nach meiner Meinung gefragt. Du willst mich jetzt überzeugen, weil ich finde die Blauen besser. Und dann führt man eigentlich diesen viel schlimmeren Edelmanus-Streit. Weiter, und dann wird dieser Vorhang ist eigentlich nur ein schwerer Täterstatt. Aber auch interessant, dass man sich dann am dritten Date bei Ikea so verhält wie echte Paare. Absolut, man ist eigentlich schon weiter.
Aber zumindest hat sie die Möglichkeit dann zu sagen, bist du jetzt so gereizt wegen der Edamame oder was?
Nein, es ist alles. Es ist deine Erfrischungstuchkur, es sind diese ganzen Bananen, die du in der Weltgeschichte rumschneidest und die ganzen driftenden Autos hinter uns, die sich drehen.
Es sind diese vielen Edamame, die du aus dem Fenster wirfst.
Es ist ein, was wir jetzt hier im Moment haben, die du aus dem Fenster wirfst. Es sind die vielen Dinge, die du aus dem Fenster wirfst. Es kommt ein bisschen viel zusammen bei dir, Linda. Aber das ist doch organisch. Du hast keine Vorhänge? Okay, also du sagst, der Grund, warum ich das frage, ist, ähm, ich habe letztens während der Autofahrt Ed Marmel geknabbert und die aus dem Fenster geworfen.
Alle, jedes Mal.
Ja, aber bedenke, ich sitze ja links auf dem Fahrersitz und werfe die Links auf den Mittelstreifen. Ich bin schon bei Autofahren, ich bin drei Jahre alt.
Ja, aber du weißt ja nicht, auf welcher Spur ich fahre, weil ich finde, das ist was anderes, weil du hast schon recht, wenn man als Beifahrer das Rechts rauswirft, landet es auf der Strasse, wenn du es als Fahrer links rauswirft, landet es und es gibt in der Stadt immer so Mittelstreifen mit so grünem Graszeug und da dann das da reinwerfen, warum denn nicht, wächst da ein Edamamebaum. So, okay. Dass man irgendwann im Stau die Fortschritte da abknabbeln, das wäre supergut. Im einfach linken Arm rausschrecken und dann ropp, einfach so eine Maiskolben.
Das fände ich mal geil.
Ja, ja, ja.
Nee, das finde ich okay.
Aber das Bild, weil du bist neulich an mir vorbeigefahren mit einem Carsharing-Auto und ich habe nur gesehen, dass du doll den Mund bewegt hast, aber Auge und Gesicht keine Reaktion.
Also meine erste Assoziation war deswegen offensichtlich ein Telefonat. Aber nicht irgendwie so ein privates, wie geht's dir, na, was machst du so, na gut, mir geht's auch gut. Nee, es war eher so ein ernstes, also Augen war so ein bisschen gerunzelt, Stirn war gerunzelt, also es hat sich so ein bisschen angefühlt wie Business Call. Und dann habe ich dich nachher gefragt und du meintest, nee, du hast gesungen. Das heißt, ich stelle mir dich jetzt vor. Ja, ein ernstes Lied. Wie du das ein ernstes Lied rezitierst. Ernstes Lied, ja. Ich stelle mir jetzt vor, dass du ernst singend, ohne jegliche Emotionen im Gesicht, mit Edermarmel schmeissend, was dann anscheinend macht, als ob die auch ein bisschen wütend auf die Natur ist.
Ja, das war nämlich mein Problem. Soll ich die möglichst weit wegwerfen, dann sieht ja der Fahrer hinter mir das. Aber ich dachte mir, ich habe ja so einen leichten, toten Winkel, wenn das Auto direkt hinter mir steht, kann ich, wenn ich das so direkt fallen lasse, an der Seite runterfallen lassen, dass es dann niemand merkt. Aber also du sagst No-Go, rote Red Flag.
Gut, deswegen sichere ich mich ab, bevor ich das beim nächsten Mal mache. Beim nächsten Mal mache ich es nicht mehr. Ich finde es okay, das zu machen, wenn es sich in Grenzen hält. Wenn du die ganzen Packungen in der Mame frisst. Aber zunächst in deinem Zeitmanagement. Das schaffe ich am meisten. Es geht ja auch um die Fahrsicherheit, weil wenn ich immer, während ich in diesen Topf reingreife, gucken muss, ist die Hülle leer oder voll, dann bin ich zu abgelenkt und bauen Unfall. Und davon haben wir, glaube ich, beide nichts. Ich glaube, bei einem Edamame-Wettessen würde ich zu den schnellsten, lass mich nicht lügen, fünf Prozent der Welt gehören. Übrigens lieben Gruss an die armen drei Seelen da draußen, die nicht wissen, was Edamame ist und sich die letzten 20 Minuten fragen, was geht hier vor sich. Was habe ich verpasst, weil wir leben ja auch in einer sehr, sehr kleinen Bubble. Wir erklären es auch nicht, der müsste jetzt durch. Naja, und ich bin so schnell darin, das zu essen. Ach, von vorne, senkrecht? Rausgedrückt. Nee, ich bin seitlich wie eine Mundharmonika. Ich bin wie Kalippo. Nee, ich kann so seitlich wie eine Mundharmonika, aber dann so abbeissen, dass alle Bohnen rauskommen. Ich sagte, Top 5%. Top 5% im Wettessen. Großmeister, Gustav, hat mich mal eine tolle Frage gestellt, die ich sehr gut fand. In welchem Triathlon wärst du der beste Mensch der Welt? Schöne Frage. Also du darfst dir drei Kategorien aussuchen und du musst am Ende diesen Triathlon gewinnen. Gegen alle Menschen auf dem Planeten. Also welche drei Skills hast du, die im Idealfall so wenig Schnittmenge haben, dass du am Ende der beste Mensch der Welt bist. Ich bin gerade kurz davor, EdamameSchnellessen dazuzumachen. Okay. Was sind so deine Anarbeiten, auf denen du gerade aufbaust? Ja, pretentious shit. Aha, okay. Möchtest du schnell die Wagner-Oper erkennen an der Overtüre. Du bist so cool, Stefan. Deswegen sage ich ja schon vorher nichts mehr, um mich davon abzugrenzen, von diesem ... ... prätentions. Ich weiß es nicht. Gute Frage. Schnell ein Buch durchblättern? Wie? So schnell durchblättern? Ohne eine Sorte zu über... Was sind die Regeln? Durch damit.
Ich glaube, das könnte ich recht gut.
Ich glaube, das können sehr viele Menschen sehr gut.
Einfach so wirklich ein Rechtspackendes Buch und dann... Bei dir ist doch ganz klar Parcours, Musik rückwärts erkennen und die Präsidenten der USA nach...
An ihrem Geruch erkennen.
Am Geruch erkennen.
Nee, das könnte ich, glaube ich, sehr, sehr gut, ja. Ich finde, das ist eine gute Frage. Weniger die Antworten, weil da werden alle Menschen zu prätentiösen Arschlöchern, sondern mehr so, dass man sich mal fragt, was stelle ich eigentlich mit meinem Leben an? Ja. Und ich glaube, je mehr man auch auf eine Antwort kommt, mit der man zufrieden ist und wo man sich sicher ist, dass man gewinnt, desto ein cooleres Leben und vielfältigeres Leben führt man auch. Ich glaube, ich hätte eins, weil ich habe ein recht eigenartiges Hobby und zwar kennt ihr ja wahrscheinlich, vielleicht gibt es einen Begriff dafür, aber an Glasflaschen, der Deckel, der hat ja unten am Deckel nochmal so fünf Klappen, so fünf. Es sind drei, je nach Mate. Es sind fünf, je nach Mate. Es ist manchmal drei, manchmal vier, manchmal fünf. Und so diese Stücke, die die Flasche zusammenhalten sollen, und wenn man die aufmacht, dann werden die so leicht nach außen geklappt, dann kann man die leicht eröffnen. Was für mich als Mensch, der immer irgendwas mit Übersprangungsverhandlungen braucht, immer abgeknibbelt. Abgeknibbelt, genau. Und genau, ich habe irgendwann angefangen, die zu sammeln.
Diese abgeknibbelten, und zwar
von der Mio-Mate-Flasche.
So einen dunkelblauen Deckel.
Und wie ich finde, recht
schöne Knibbel, weil die so ein bisschen
gekrümmter sind als zum Beispiel bei der
Club-Mate. Die sind so ein bisschen,
das ist schwer darzustellen,
aber die sind so ein bisschen weniger gekrümmt.
Wer das nicht kennt, wer noch nie eine Mate getrunken hat
und bei ihr da Marme Fragezeichen im Kopf hat,
der hat ein Riesenproblem.
Das ist ein Wettbewerb. schwer darzustellen, aber die sind so ein bisschen weniger getrumpft. Also wer das nicht kennt, wer noch nie eine Mate getrunken hat und bei ihr da Marme Fragezeichen im Kopf hat, der hat ein Riesenproblem heute bei der Folge. Ich sammle die und habe aber irgendwann gemerkt, das ist nicht so befriedigend, wenn ich die so einfach so wie sie sind, habe. Und dann habe ich mich entschlossen, die zu knicken. Jeder Knibbel wird einmal geknickt.
Wie? Die beiden Schenkel zueinander? Ja, einfach der Länge nach in der Mitte geknickt. Und in der Form sammle ich die. Ich habe dann so einen metallenen Teefilter, also das ist wie so ein Kolben, wo so ganz viele Löcher drin sind, wie so ein Filter, und da sind die drin. Und das heisst, immer wenn ich Mate trinke, sammle ich die und irgendwann dann so einmal im Monat oder so setze ich mich hin und habe dann meinen Haufen Knibbel und die werden dann in der Mitte geknickt und da reingetan. Moment, Moment, du knibbelst, du machst die nicht sofort so da rein? Nein, die werden erst zwischengelagert und dann mache ich mir eine schöne Serie an und dann knicke ich die einfach alle zusammen. Und das ist nicht so leicht, wie du denkst,
weil du musst ja am Anfang schon mit deinem Fingernagel genau den Punkt treffen, der genau die Mitte ist.
Und manchmal knickst du die zusammen und merkst,
oh, eine Seite steht leicht über, und dann werden die aussortiert.
Nein!
Ja, werden aussortiert.
Und mittlerweile bin ich aber so gut darin,
die wirklich so zu knicken, weil manchmal,
weil dein Fingernagel hat ja auch eine gewisse Dicke, das heißt diese Falz kannst du während dem Knicken noch leicht in eine Richtung lenken, das ist schwer nachzuvollziehen, das müsst ihr vielleicht zu Hause mal probieren, aber mittlerweile kann ich das so gut. Du sprichst nämlich zu 0,25 Prozent der Hörerinnen, weil ich mache das selber, ich knicke das selber und ich kann dir schon nicht mehr folgen. Ich bin selber ein Mate-Knicker. Ja, ja, ja. Und deswegen glaube ich, bin ich da mittlerweile so gut, weil ich jeden Monat die wirklich wegknicke und sammle und halt wirklich immer denke, weil du hast völlig rechtlich mit deinen vor Panik aufgerissenen Augen reagiert, als ich gesagt habe, die werden aussortiert. Das willst du natürlich nicht. Du willst sie nicht sammeln über Wochen und dann denen aussortieren, sondern du willst sie exakt, und ich kriege es mittlerweile wirklich in 90 Prozent der Fällen hin, dass sie so perfekt geknickt werden, dass sie wirklich mit den Enden direkt aufeinander landen und dann werden die gesammelt. Und ich glaube, da könnte ich so ziemlich jeden Menschen auf der Welt schlagen. Eine Kunstausstellung mit sowas. Ja. Da brauchst du noch 20 andere Ausstellungsstücke und dann wäre ich zufrieden. Und diese Ausstellung würde ich mir sehr gerne angucken. Das fände ich richtig cool, wenn da so ein Riesenglas stünde, mit einer wirklich lächerlichen Menge von diesen Mate-Dingern. Fände ich das total cool. Für mich kann auch ein Kunstwerk sein, diese geplatzte Dose aus deinem Kühlschrank. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Aber die sah wirklich cool aus, weil das würde man nicht erwarten, wie die platzt, weil die hat sich, weil Dosen sind ja unten so nach innen gewölbt. Mhm. Ja, ja. Nee, nee. Konkav. Okay. Oder nicht, hatte ich doch, kommt halt immer auf den Betrachtern. Ja, das ist immer das Problem. Und dann wird das erst mal nach außen gewölbt, dann hast du so eine richtige Beule da und dann wird es noch mal weiter gedient und dann erst reisst es. Also dass da richtig gut ist. Aber ich stimme dir zu, das Museum ist im Gange. Und die Ausstellung heißt Loss of Control. Loss of Control? Ich finde schon. Lots of Control, würde ich sagen. Dann ist da ein T nach dazwischen, ein nerviges in Klammern. Und was ich auch lange gesammelt habe, war von ... Oder Boring Life.
No Life.
Von diesen Soja-Joghurt-Packungen, diese 500-milliliter-Joghurt-Packungen, die hatten oben so einen Deckel drauf, so einen durchsichtigen Plastikdeckel.
Den habe ich immer gesammelt, weil die konnte man supergut stapeln.
Und eines Tages, als ich kurz davor war, irgendwie 100 Stück zu haben, stand dann drauf, ja, für den Umweltschutz, um Müll zu reduzieren, haben wir diesen Deckel jetzt entfernt. Und die werden jetzt ohne Deckel verkauft, du hast jetzt nur noch so diese Lasche drauf. Also ich war, ich war, war außer mir, war außer mir. Und ich gesagt habe, was soll das hier heißen mit Müll, die kommen nicht in Müll, ich sammle die doch, die stehen zu Hause rum, das ist doch kein Müll! Ich könnte dafür sorgen, dass sie damit, ohne neue zu produzieren, nochmal die nächsten drei Jahre lang klarkommt. Ja genau, mach doch ein Pfandsystem. Bei mir steht das eben nicht im Müll. Also das habe ich mich echt geärgert. Da ist bei mir ein Hobby gestorben. Okay, okay. Du hast früher wahrscheinlich auch von Kugelschreibern so diese kleinen Kugeln. Nee, von Füllern habe ich die Kugeln gesammelt. Ach so, die Tintenpatronen. Die Tintenpatronen, da war ja immer eine Kugel drin, die habe ich gesammelt. Ja, hast du die auch noch irgendwo? Nein. Ja, weil dann muss man das durchziehen. Die sind mittlerweile viel wert, die sind mittlerweile richtig viel wert. Das sind ein bisschen die Bitcoins, ja, ja. Ich finde die nicht mehr. Das wäre immer geil. Irgendwo. Können wir nicht so als Gegen, weil klar, Barzahlung stirbt aus, geht immer mehr in Richtung Cryptocurrency, blablabla. Wäre nicht geil, wenn wir wieder so ein bisschen analoges, wie so ein analoges Krypto. Ja, wie so Muscheln oder so. Ja, genau. Weil diese Kugelschreiberkugeln fände ich dafür eigentlich ziemlich gut. Oder so alte Yu-Gi-Oh! Karten. Ja, das darf halt nicht fälschbar sein, so was. Alte Yu-Gi-Oh! Karten. Nurarten. Nur alte. Jogio-Karten. Okay. Nee, problematisch wird es halt dann, wenn du die noch kaufen kannst. Ja. Weil dann wird es ja. Ja, und dann kann halt irgendeine Firma in Japan die unendlich drucken und es ist unendlich reich. Dann drucken die wie Gelddrucken. Ja, im Grunde. Das heißt, dann wird das unsere Zentral-Konami, wird unsere Zentralbank und da hätte ich dann wiederum ganz grosse Probleme. Ja, wo stehen die politisch, weiß man nicht. Weiß ich nicht. Man kann die Yogi-O-Karten gerne angucken und nach politischen Aussagen durchfilzen. Ich mach's nicht. So, wir sind noch immer in unserer Dino-Rubrik. Nein! Ich hab extra versucht, abzulenken, damit wir nicht zu den schlechten Nachrichten kommen. Die schlechten ... Ich hab noch eine gute Nachricht, wohl heute kam erst raus, gelesen hab ich bei uns in unserem Reddit. Und zwar habe ich herausgefunden, da... Von wem kannst du den Namen nennen? Ich werde kurz den Namen nennen, lass mich kurz mal unseren Reddit-Mitglied. Das finde ich muss schon sein, also wenn du dich da schon darauf beziehst, dann nennst doch einfach, das ist doch kein Problem. Da hast du total recht. Schau mal, Ricardion, Ricardion schreibt, oh boys and girls, wir sind wieder auf Kurs, Megaraptor mit 35 cm langen Klauen entdeckt.
Yes! Yes! Wuh! Wuh!
Raptor!
Wir haben es geschafft, also es wurde ein Megaraptor gefunden mit
35 m langen Clown.
Der sieht nicht bescheuert aus.
Der sehr agile Spitzen-Prä-Dator,
also ein Apex-Predator aus der späten Kreidezeit, lebt im heutigen Patagonien. Das liegt wo, Flonien? Patapattapatta und er reichte eine Länge von zehn Metern. Megaraptoren verdienen zwar schluss ihren martialischen Namen, die Gruppe Theropoda-Dinosaurier brachte gegen Ende der Kreidezeit tatsächlich riesige Räuber hervor. Den gewaltigsten von ihnen hat nun ein Paläontologenteam in Patagonien, Argentinien freigelegt. Die verstanderten Überreste weisen auf einen bisher unbekannten Fleischfresser hin, der zu Lebzeiten vor etwa 70 Millionen Jahren. Mega, also das ist spannend, lese ich das mal durch, findet ihr im Reddit. Also man sieht, da passiert noch was und so und man darf es auch nicht aufgeben. Und klar, wir haben so ein paar Rückschritte einstecken müssen, aber es geht auch noch weiter. Aber jetzt kommt es zu den schlechten Neuigkeiten, den schlechten T-Rex-Neuigkeiten, Florentin. Aber ich finde das schon mal gut, 35 cm Klauen, das ist schon mal enorm. Dafür zählt nur nicht so was kommen wie, die hat er benutzt, um den anderen den Rücken zu kraulen oder auf dem Rücken zu kratzen. Damit konnte er sich sehr gut in seinen Gehörgängen, wo sich grosse Parasiten drin festgefangen haben. Damit konnte er sich gut im Augapfel kratzen einfach. Aber ich mag auch dieses Diagramm, ist jetzt sehr unzugänglich, dieses Diagramm, wo diese Raptoren gegenübergestellt werden, eine Menschengrösse, und der Mensch einfach gefangen ist zwischen ganz vielen Raptoren, links und rechts, sie stürmen von allen Seiten auf ihn ein. Es ist einfach nicht ganz objektiv, dieses Grösse. Das Blut hätte es auch in diesem Diagramm nicht gebraucht. So, aber jetzt bist du bereit für die schlechte Neuigkeit? Ja. So, und zwar hat man nämlich die Nebenhöhlen eines Tieres. Warum? Geht auf die Klauen, die Pranken, die Stampforgane, schaut dem doch nicht in die Nase, ey. Man hat sich die Nashöhlen eines ... Warum? Geht auf die Klauen, die pranken die Stampforgane!
Schaut dem doch nicht in die Nase, ey!
Man hat sich die Nasennebenhöhlen eines Dinosauriers mal genauer angeguckt,
und zwar des T-Rex.
Und man hat herausgefunden, dass Dinosaurier,
also der T-Rex jetzt genauer genommen,
26 Liter Schleim in sich trug jedes Mal.
Das heißt, wenn er geniesst hat, kamen 26 Liter Schleim in sich trug, jedes Mal. Das heißt, wenn er geniesst hat, kam 26 Liter purer Schleim. Das ist, glaube ich, der chemische Ausdruck, Schleim, raus. Okay, da will ich jetzt aber auch einen Vergleich haben, wie viel Liter hat der Mensch. Nasen, Nebenhöhlen, Liter Mensch. 26 Liter Schleim. Hör mir! Oh, um Gottes Willen, Entschuldigung. Entschuldigung, Ihre ganze Familie. Oh Gott, das tut mir ja sehr leid. Also jetzt ist ja die ganze Vorschulklasse. Oh, das tut mir leid. Jetzt ist ja alles ... Schleim, Liter, Mensch. Das heißt, er braucht eigentlich auch ein riesiges Taschentuch. Im Grunde braucht er der T-Rex ein riesiges Taschentuch. Das ist ja witzig. Zwei Liter am Tag produziert der Mensch an Lungenschleim. Naja. Lungenschleim? Ja. Schnuder. Das ist ja auch ein gutes Wort. Was? Top drei Wörter für Schleim. Schnuder, Schlodder.
Ja, Schnuder gibt es.
In der Lunge wird Schleim und das wird dann hochgeröchelt oder was?
Nee, ist aber wie man krank ist. Ist egal, findet man nicht, reichlich nach.
Aber auf jeden Fall sechsmal Liter ist eine Menge, würde man, ja, also drin baden können.
Und da kommt auch dann dieses Schniefding her, dass der T-Rex immer erkältet war und geschnieft hat. Ein bisschen wo schnief war, ne? Zue Nase, hat er auch immer so gesprochen. Das Ding ist, was mich aber inzwischen ohne Scheißfrage ist, ich weiß das nicht mal von Kühen oder Tieren, mit denen wir viel mehr gerade noch zu tun haben, die wirklich noch am Leben sind, mit denen wir Tag für Tag umgehen müssen. Ja, das stimmt.
Ich weiß es von keinem Tier.
Wer finanziert diese Forschung? Welche Lobby ist dahinter, den T-Rex einfach fertig zu machen?
Nee, ich glaube, es ist einfach spannend, weil das der T-Rex ist.
Aber ich finde das jetzt langsam kontraproduktiv, weil ich meine, man sollte ja eher wissen, wie viel,
also selbst Nasennebenhüllen, gut, bei einem Elefanten oder so ist auch egal. Zählt der Rüssel da dazu oder was? Der hat nochmal so viel wie der Rüssel nach innen. Lass mal so einen krassen, ausgewachsenen Elefanten gegen T-Rex kämpfen. Oh ja. Ich meine so ein richtiges. Oh ja. Oder Mammut halt direkt. Ich glaube, das ist der Kampf. Der ultimative Kampf. Mammut-T-Rex. Mammuts hatten auch Rüssel, oder? Auch Fell auf dem Rüssel. Ja. Oder, weil ich meine, so ein Hund, der hat ja auch auf der Schnauz hat er ja Fell. Woher weiss man, ob der Mammut auf dem Rüssel Fell hatte oder nicht? Weil ich glaube nicht, dass das so dargestellt wird. Müssen wir eigentlich auch mal übers Mammut reden? Entschuldigung. Müssen wir nicht eigentlich ab einem gewissen Punkt, na doch, doch, doch, guck mal, der hat einen Fellrüssel. Fellrüssel. Aber manchmal nicht. In manchen Darstellungen hat er einen Fellrüssel, in manchen nicht. Woher wissen wir, dass das Fell nur so kurz war auf dem Rüssel? Woher wissen wir, dass der nicht so einen schönen Perückenrüssel hatte? So einen richtigen, wie ist dieser Staubwischer? Halt einfach so einen riesen, riesen Fellrüssel. Ich verstehe den Hype ums Mammut nicht, weil es das einfach gibt. Elefanten, gut, die haben die nicht behaart, aber haben auch Stosszähne. Die Haare machen es, die Haare machen es. Die Haare machen es, aber haben Stosszähne und so. Ja, haben einfach die Fell verloren, sind eigentlich wieder da. Deswegen verstehe ich nicht so ganz den Hype, sollen aber jetzt wieder gelebt werden. Es ist nicht Elon Musk auch am Start, Mammuts zu aus dem Harz, aus dem Blut von dem Harz eingeschlossenen Mücken zu züchten, ich weiß nicht. Das ist auch so, manchmal die Natur checke ich auch nicht, weil sowas wie ein Fell, das ist ja absolut wichtig für so einen Löwen, überlebenswichtig, erkennbar, oder einfach für so eine Katze irgendwie, damit die im Winter überleben kann. Aber dann gibt es einfach eins, da hat er einfach keinen Fell. Es gibt Katzen, die haben das halt einfach nicht. Das ist, wenn man manche Tiere Arme haben und andere einfach
brauchen sie nicht. Hat das nicht die Allergiker-Lobby
einfach jahrzehntelang
Oh, das stimmt, das kann auch sein.
Haben die das Fell weggezüchtet?
Ja. Nein. Also die mit den wenigsten
Fell genommen und gekreuzt
und am Ende weggezüchtet. Echt? Ich dachte,
es gab eine Rasse schon immer, die hatte kein Fell,
aber du hast recht. Ist der Elefant
dann auch von der Allergiker-Lobby? Was haben die alles auf dem Gewissen eigentlich? Nacktmull, Mammut, Schlange. Wie so ein langes Mikrofon. Die Reptilien haben wir erschlossen. Amphilien erschlossen. Das ist eigentlich auch mal so im Hauptquartier der Allergiker. Einfach Hünne, Hünne, Hünne. So, kommen wir nun zu unserem Lagebericht. Diese Tiere haben wir bereits fellfrei gezüchtet. So eine Kriegskarte im Hintergrund mit so Fell von so Tieren, die man so erschlossen hat. Aber ich wollte gerade sagen, krass, wir als Alekha-Lobby haben bereits alle Amphibien und Riptilien erschlossen.
Klar, natürlich, weil Fell im Wasser kontraproduktiv ist und schlecht ist.
Korrekt.
Aber bestimmt nicht. Also Biber haben Fell, Otter haben Fell.
Die beiden Dinge, Biene, schwimmen im Wasser und haben Fell.
Ja.
Nichts anderes, gut.
Polabe, Eisbär.
Gewisse Seerobben haben vielleicht auch Fell.
Ja.
Eisbär haben Fell.
Das kann schon sein, ja. Aber dass das Mammut, dass es einfach ausgerottet wurde, das ist schon verrückt. Aber auch da weiss man jetzt auch nicht, wie viele Liter Nasennebenhöhlen-Shit da drin ist. Also mich nervt das ein bisschen, dass wir jetzt beim T-Rex offensichtlich mehr, also hat mehr Nachrichtenwert direkt. Also jetzt werden noch so eklliche Details bekannt, brauche ich jetzt nicht alles. Aber gut. Nee, wir brauchen jetzt wirklich nicht alles. Wie viel Ohrenschmalz hatte so ein T-Rex die ganze Zeit? Irgendwie hat er so einen Aschenbecher oder so, der die ganze Zeit voll war? Wie gut war seine Singstimme? Brauche ich nicht. Das brauchen wir alles nicht. Es sei denn, sie war furchterregend schrecklich. Ja, zum Beispiel. Warum sehnen wir uns so nach einem Monster eigentlich?
Hm, okay. Ist das irgendwie zeitgemäß? Schöne Frage. Ich mag, dass wir die letzten fünf Minuten immer noch mal so ein bisschen ins Philosophische, wirklich Menschliche gehen. Warum konstruieren wir uns Monster? Nee, weil warum resoniert, weil diese Frage, ich meine, wir kriegen, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir ist, Aber ich kriege für kein anderes Thema so viele Instagram-Direct-Messages oder irgendwelche Nachrichten bei Twitter wie jetzt bei den Dinosauriern, bei unserer Dino-Rubrik. Und das scheint ja auf gewisse Resonanz zu stoßen. Warum? Warum sehnen wir uns so sehr nach Monstern? Warum brauchst du den Furcht der Regeln in den T-Rex? Ich, vielleicht, weil wir sie eigentlich umbringen wollen. Weil wir wollten eigentlich der Drachentöter sein. Die ganze Geschichte ist voll von Helden-Geschichten, Drachentöter. Und ich glaube auch, dass die Mammuts nicht ausgerottet wurden, weil die so lecker waren, die können nicht so lecker gewesen sein, wohin mit dem ganzen Fell, sondern weil du einfach aufwächst und du wächst auf und du kommst in die Pubertät und du siehst so eine Fussspur und du kannst dich in diese Fussspur reinlegen. So vielleicht als Eröffnungsszene, die Kinder baden. Genau, die baden in so einem vom Regen vollgelaufenen Mammutspur und die Kinder sagen, was muss das für ein riesiges Tier sein. Einer sagt, eines Tages werde ich so einen Mammut töten und dann passiert es auch oder nicht. Keine Ahnung, aber ich glaube, du willst einfach Dinge, die grösste sind, einfach zu Fall bringen. Und ich glaube, diese Mammutfaszination und die T-Rex fasziniert uns die, dass man sich denkt, den hätte ich gepackt. Und irgendwie ist dieses reine Böse ja auch irgendwie beruhigend, oder nicht? T-Rex ist böse? Wir haben so eine Monster also wir haben so eine Monster-Romantik. Wir sehnen uns nach dem Monster. Wir wollen das reine Böse. Davor hast du Angst und das ist klar und das ist groß. Sobald wir etwas bekommen wie, ah, der konnte gar nicht so schnell laufen, ah, der war ein bisschen tollpatschig, der ist ein bisschen hingefallen, ah, der hatte graue Haare, sagen wir alle, oh Gott, oh Gott, und lachen uns darüber kaputt. Warum? Weil wir eigentlich ein feuchterregendes Monster wollen. Und das zu wissen, dass sowas mehr existiert, ist ja auf eine gewisse Weise auch, weiß nicht, beruhigend. Man hat sowas ultimative Böse irgendwie. Warum gibt es das denn eigentlich nicht mehr? Warum gibt es nicht so riesige Monstertiere? Ja, die werden also Haie noch am ehesten. Aber ich habe mal gehört, dass das auch was mit, dass das auch was mit Kohlendioxid zu tun hat, dass früher mehr, ich glaube, also korrigiert mich, macht uns das böse, dass je mehr Sauerstoff in der Luft ist, desto grösser können Tiere werden, sowas grob, ganz grob, vielleicht ist es auch genau andersrum, aber irgendwo liegt ein Zusammenhang und dass je mehr, jetzt ich sage jetzt Kohlendioxid, das kann natürlich irgendwas anderes sein, desto weniger ergiebig die Luft ist, so kleiner müssen Tiere werden. Oder vielleicht ist es genau andersrum. Je weniger Sauerstoff, desto größer müssen Lungen sein, damit man überhaupt leben kann. Und desto größer muss man sein, irgendwas, denkt euch halt irgendwas aus, irgendeine Kausalität ist mir nicht egal. Aber es gibt gewisse Umwelteinflüsse, die dafür sorgen, dass Tiere größer sind.
Mein Gott, ey.
Aber es sind auch Haie.
Die bösesten Tiere haben ja auch die grösseste Fan- oder Feindlobby.
An den kann man sich so schön reichen. Haie sind auch nicht böse.
Nee, aber auch in Richtung dieses Monsters,
was wir uns alle wünschen.
Gibt uns da mal Antwortmöglichkeiten.
Warum sehen wir uns alle nach dem Monster?
Wir wünschen euch eine monsterfreie nächste Woche. Und ein bisschen Kritik auch, weil letzte Woche hatte ich ja aufgerufen. Ah ja. Was hatte ich aufgerufen? Zu welchem Thema hatte ich einen Aufruf gestartet? Du hast ein Thema ... Letzte Woche war ja die ... ... Liveshow. Mhm. Davor? Nee, das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Nee, letzte Woche hast du nämlich gefragt, Körperöffnung. Nee, nee, nee, das ist schon zwei Wochenende. Letzte Woche hast du gefragt, was denn eigentlich los ist mit unseren Bäumen, mit dem Wind. Warum windet es denn hier so sehr? Warum, ah, niesen! Warum Pollen uns die Lungen zerfräsen? Dann weiß es nicht. Schau vielleicht mal auf deine Uhr. Habe ich nicht. Die Datumsgrenze, die Datumsgrenze, verschiebt die Datumsgrenze, unsere Petition. Sanduhr. Sanduhren. Warum ob Sanduhren alle, ob manipulierbar sind, ob Sand und Sand. Warum Sand nicht schneller rieselt, je mehr Sand oben drin ist, warum das das nicht rausdrückt. Das war auch eine Frage, meine Frage war, ob es verschiedene Sandarten gibt. Genau, und wir haben alle Geologen oder Steinwissenschaftler gefragt, uns die Antwort zu geben, aber in einer künstlerisch anspruchsvollen Form. Wir haben gesagt, schreibt uns Gedichte, schreibt uns Limmericks, wir wollen keinen langweiligen, ich wollte nur mal sagen, dass das so und so ist, sondern wählt mal ein neues Medium. Und wir haben eine Einreichung bekommen von Pomegranate Boring, der uns ein Sandgedicht geschrieben hat. Ich bin euer Sandmann, studiere Geografie noch nicht allzu lang. Sand ist ein Sediment, das die ganze Welt kennt. Doch weiss ich über Sand, es hängt nur ab vom Massband. Sand meint alles von 0,063 bis 2 mm die deutsche Industrienorm, definierte einst des Sandes Form. Ich hoffe, ihr jagt das mit der nächsten Folge über den Äther. Vielen Dank an Pomegranate Boring für dieses schöne Sache, dass die Fragen jetzt nicht, ehrlich gesagt nicht beantwortet, aber einen schönen Einblick in diese herrliche Mikrowelt von Sand. Das hilft, dass wir nicht überschüttet werden mit Nachrichten, finde ich, wenn wir so eine, es ist wie so ein Capture. Ja, wenn wir so eine künstlerische Grenze schaffen, einfach so ein kreatives Niveau, das überschritten werden muss.
Genau, das finde ich super. Das sollten wir uns beibehalten für alle anderen Fragen.
Es gibt noch sehr viele Fragen richtungsamt jetzt.
Ja. Aber das klären wir alles demnächst.
Aber ich bin mir sicher, ich werde es wieder vergessen.
Haut rein, wir wünschen euch eine ganz, ganz tolle Woche. Lasst euch nicht verjagen und macht's gut. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Bei Cool Top!
Oh, it's the worst bird production.